également également ce soir j'aimerais
avoir deux personnes du public
elle qui ne s'y attend dé moi je vais
demander à l'est peut-être à ce monsieur
qui est là oui allez formidable
messieurs de nancy de paris par vidal
est en train de se coter ou madame
c'était dame en rouge oui vous venez
m'aider or il n'y a pas de problème on
encourage également madame ou
mademoiselle
donnez moi la main s'il vous plaît je
vous ai fait attendre toute petite
seconde je suis désolé voilà va très
bien merci
c'est très facile je vous demande
simplement d'ouvrir et de fermer la
bouche sans parler uniquement soucier
regardé comme un poisson très bien alors
essayé avec vous monsieur aux avancées
un tout petit peu je vous remercie vous
êtes avec l'équipe de nancy
non oui objectif de nancy a très bien
supporté
alors lorsque j'appuie une fois sur
votre main vous ouvrez une fois la
bouche hockey lorsque j'appuie 2 vous
ouvrez deux fois un peu moi ça a l'air
de marcher très très bien
vous avez compris et c'est pas
douloureux et non non non non non non
non voilà là et quelle jolie voix merci
beaucoup
vous êtes bariteau s'est gardé de
nogarède en organisant à paris d'après
midi si on va essayer corrida
attention c'est à vous est ce que vous
êtes prêt au bon dieu qu'est-ce qui se
passe auj
ces couacs avec vous êtes un petit peu
enrhumé aucun de l'eau que dans l'eau
que naulleau et cette fois vous avez
perdu l'accent yolande moreau
ça va bien alors écoutez vous avez vous
repensé pour la dernière chanson merci
beaucoup on oublie ou non lieu dont il
évolue et volubile madame très bien
merci
alors regardez regardez le public ne me
regardez pas et tant que vous michel
vous êtes prêts
aulas ça va très bien et aériens ça vous
fait pas mal non plus anna zizi a
réservé you speak english est ici ce
soir nous avons une très jolie femme
ouvrez un peu plus loin la bouche et de
ne pas fâcher un petit peu timide quand
même un première fois un télévision
c'est la première fois mais ça va très
bien et si ça va pas
alors il ya un habitué non je croyais
que vous dormiez est ce que je peux vous
demander quelque chose ici
ouvrez un peu plus grand la bouche oh là
là elle est en colère
alors dites-moi est-ce que vous êtes
marié maras histoire elle avait entendu
ça vous intéresse elle est très jolie
voulait l'épouser
et vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous voulez réfléchir alors en fait ça
avec une petite chanson musique s'il
vous plaît enfin vous restez ici
merci bien vous même ici je me mets ici
donnée - 7 7 mais monsieur voilà et
enrico cette manne merci
ici
nous devons vous
agricoles prédit pendant près de douze
ou dix jours
la la
pas
m
merci beaucoup